settlers of catan is one of the best
selling board games of all time
and nestled in the rolling hills of
rossdorf germany
on this picturesque street
past the buzzer in building 43 and
standing in the back of the garden is
klaus tuber
the man who made it all happen
settlers of catan is a board game for up
to four players where you collect
resources to build settlements and
cities
they're worth points first to 10 wins
and it all started like this
in the 90s and 80s
i led a dental laboratory
developing games was a little bit
refuge for me
his first game was called barbarossa
when i made barbarossa i was in my early
30s i feel that this is a kind of thing
i like very much developing games and it
could be in the future for me a
very very good hobby
he designed a handful of other games and
then
made katan
klaus had become interested in viking
tales
yes the story of the vikings inspired me
i imagine how they reach iceland they
need wood they need houses and all the
things and so on this imagination
idea without cutting
from design to market it was a family
affair
this is benny tuber he lives in germany
and he is klaus's youngest son
and this is ghettotuber
and this is guidotuber he lives in san
francisco he is klaus's eldest son
in my family i am one of the game
testers along with my mom
me too
we play tested the settlers of catan
quite often
we would all get together at the dining
room table and would test and has his
games
sometimes he put a mickey mouse comic
next to my chair so in case the game was
boring he knew that i would read it
instead of playing the game
my dad took that and
tweaked that worked on it this was sort
of an exciting moment for my dad
in the tuber family there's a bit of
competition my father would probably say
i'm the best player
no
sorry dad
benny is the best
there's a bit of a rivalry between my
dad and my brother
katan was officially released in germany
in 1994 and it was an immediate success
we had an immediate success in germany
because we won game of the year
worldwide to date over 24 million copies
have been sold this game was born out of
a story but it also creates stories the
beauty of catan is that in the end you
still have constructed something so in a
way everybody wins
it was my wish to have a very peaceful
game with a lot of interaction bringing
people together for me catan was a
success
to all the katan fans out there here's
some advice
well you always have to follow your
strategy but also you have to complain
quite a bit even though you know you're
winning you still have to say you're not
i love building cities as early as
possible in the game
never built the
longest road at the beginning
and there you have it
you